good afternoon everybody anybody see who
got the Pulitzer Prize remember that
cancer book I told you about so I was
right was it is good today we are going
to talk about emerging viruses which is
really an extension of last lecture last
chapter we talked about how new viruses
evolve so today we're going to see how
they go from one host to another so an
emerging virus is an agent of a new or
previously unrecognized infection so it
doesn't have to be brand new it could be
something that's been around but we just
haven't detected it before it's our
definition it's actually a term that was
coined in the 90s hadn't existed before
that but as you will see they're not new
they certainly aren't just starting in
the 1990s and basically since their eyes
of Agriculture about 11,000 years ago
infectious agents have invaded human
populations more frequently because the
populations have become larger and
that's because in part of agriculture
and part of that was domesticating
animals and so you had the numbers of
individuals susceptible individuals that
could sustain infections now she's not
to say that before eleven thousand years
ago we did not get infected but it was
rarer and probably not epidemic
sometimes an emerging infection is
really the what happens in aachen it
expanded host range of a virus so it's a
virus that's been around and infected
certain animals that we know about but
for some reason the host range changes
and we'll talk about today what kind of
things cause these hosts ranges it can
also be transmission of a virus from an
animal to humans what we call zoonosis
alright we have mentioned a couple of
times before in this course this is most
often what we think about when we talk
about emerging viruses sometimes the zoo
no seas or the zune
nautic infections establish a new virus
in the population as we discussed for
HIV which moved from chimps to humans as
far as HIV 1 goes sometimes
cross-species infection a zoonosis
cannot be sustained so for HIV the
cross-species infection was obviously
sustained but for ebola and marburg we
have sporadic outbreaks where the virus
goes from a bat to a human there are
some infections of healthcare workers
because they happen to be close to the
sick people and they get infected with
blood or other fluids but for the most
part the virus is not transmitted well
and the press loves emerging infections
here's a newsweek cover with the killer
virus beyond the Ebola scare what else
is out there well as you'll see there's
plenty out there this is actually one of
the first books to talk about these
emerging infections Lassa fever virus
which emerged in the 60s is discussed in
this book and this is the book that made
me want to become a virologist when i
read it many years ago actually a lot of
it takes place up at Columbia this
started in Africa and one of the sick
nurses she was airlifted to Columbia
they put her in a passenger 747 I just
put her in one of the seats and flew her
to Colombia and they put her in
intensive care Colombia she actually
recovered and then a virologist working
on the virus infected himself and he
lived his name was your D Casals he
lived in Upper Manhattan and he worked
at Yale so they admitted him to Columbia
and they gave him the serum of the nurse
who had recovered and that saved his
life this is pretty cool story so anyway
yeah that's why I'm a virologist because
of stuff like that so that was the first
one I think the first story so there are
many factors that determine or allow
viruses to change species or to change
and emerge in some way these are six vet
factors that drive emergence we'll talk
about some of these today and give you
specific examples there are physical
environmental factors of course the
microbe in the virus itself are
important than there
illusion ecological factors social
political and economic fact this was
important for the spread of AIDS the
movement of populations in Africa wars
etc human and animal factors and finally
genetic and biochemical ones in
biological ones and a in a really
overriding factor that drives viral
emergence is human population growth and
basically that changes the environment
we modify everything by building into
new areas we're occupying almost every
corner of the planet you can see by this
map here which shows city lights how
occupy how the planet is occupied their
parts of the of South America of course
that are not terribly connell colonized
and as you'll see there are many viruses
there and eventually we will colonize
these regions and probably identify new
infections in the process some more
elaborations on this again forces of
disease emerges globalization and air
travel has played a huge role in
spreading diseases very rapidly we alter
the ecosystems all the time we go into
new areas DeForest them and we encounter
mosquitoes with viruses in them
environmental changes the used tire
trade has played a big role in spreading
infections because you can never get rid
of all the water from a used tire it's
very difficult you'd have to take each
one and dump it out ever you ever tried
to dump water out of a tire you get some
out of the bottom and then it goes to
the top and you turn it so it's really
hard and then if you put them on a ship
they get filled with water again so they
carry mosquito eggs the evolution of
microbes is important we talked about
that last time population growth of
course and in particular poverty which
prevents people from being immunized
against many infectious diseases and
then deforestation cutting down trees so
we can build there and then we go into
environments where there are viruses we
haven't seen before and the global
aviation network is huge right now you
can go anywhere in a very short time and
carrier viruses with you and we will see
this playing a role in many infections
the topic of last time evolution of
course plays an important role in all of
these animals wherever they are on earth
their viruses multiplying and they are
evolving in those animals and that
allows the viruses to adapt to new hosts
and environments by selection like we
talked about last time and it also leads
to microbial resistance don't forget
that that's an important part of this as
well just to give you an example of the
numbers of viruses out there this is
just a map of the amazon north region of
brazil and these dots are areas where
viruses have been isolated by this
institute they are in brazil and you can
see each of these each of these names is
a different virus and these are just the
ones that have been isolated they're
plenty more out there that we don't even
know about so as we move into the Amazon
and DeForest it for construction and
wood who knows what infections will pick
up so these are some of the emerging
viruses that we know about that we have
studied in the past few decades we'll
talk about a few of these today dengue
virus we have talked a good amount about
and of course that has emerged since the
1980s primarily as a result of the tire
trade bringing it around the world Ebola
virus is emerged from a probably a bat
reservoir to infect humans but very
sporadically we'll talk about
hantaviruses today we have talked about
HIV influenza virus emerges every year
basically because of the integrated pig
duck agriculture that we've talked about
the virus is in all kinds of birds and
we we sustain the numbers and
reassortment by having pigs and ducks
right next to each other noroviruses
we've just recently discovered because
we couldn't grow them we had methods for
detecting names but they are still an
emerging infection and West Nile virus
seen nombre we'll talk about today which
emerged from mice from human road in
contact and West Nile virus
which was present in much of the world
but not in the US and we'll talk about
actually Deeks Dixon de Paume yay we'll
talk about that in the last lecture of
this course so to understand how viruses
emerge we have to look at the kinds of
interactions that viruses have with
their hosts and those are shown on this
slide and there are really four main
kinds of interactions the first is a
stable interaction where the virus and
the hosts have been together for a long
time this maintains the virus in the
ecosystem many often times the hosts are
fine they're not getting six on this
infection then there are what we course
resistant infections where host the
virus is transferred to a new host but
the host is not susceptible to infection
so that doesn't result in anything
happening there are evolving infections
when the virus first enters a species
and these are typically a naive
population that hasn't seen the virus
before and the virus is changing as well
as the host so the rabbits infected with
myxoma virus that we talked about last
time it's an evolving infection because
the rabbits and the virus are changing
every year and then we have dead end
systems where it's a one-way street the
virus goes from a animal into humans but
it doesn't spread among humans so Ebola
this an example of that does not really
spread extensively amongst humans in
stable host virus interactions as I've
said both the virus and the host survive
and multiply sometimes these are
permanent interactions and there's some
human examples measles virus herpes
simplex cytomegalovirus smallpox these
are all essentially human infections
they are not without disease of course
but they're stable within the human
population and sometimes these viruses
may infect more than one species in
addition to us so influenza a viruses we
have said infects many different kinds
of animal species besides humans
flavie's and togas as well now infecting
just people isn't a great strategy you
take a bit of a risk but that's the way
evolution works right the there is no
long-term view in evolution there is
just
works for the moment so you have I want
you to remember that when a virus is
evolving in the host it's not thinking
about 10 years down the road it's not
evolving for 10 years down the road it's
evolving for what works at that moment
so at some point viruses evolved to
infect just humans but of course if we
disappear the viruses are gone too and
over the years many species have
disappeared and they've taken their
viruses with them so it must be a risk
that is it that evolution takes because
it happens over and over again an
evolving host virus relationship the one
where the virus is newly introduced into
species is typically in state unstable
the infection can be benign or a can
result in death depends on many factors
and some of the examples are when
smallpox and measles virus were
introduced into Native Americans by the
colonists the old-world colonists and
slave traders and that devastated these
populations introduction of West Nile
into the western hemisphere in 1999 so
the virus came here from somewhere else
it wasn't devastating was it was far
more benign than and neither of these
incidences so the fact that this is
evolving means that there can be a lot
of outcomes the virus may evolve to
increase its spread which may also lead
to an increase in virulence it may or
may not and the host may also change and
that can force the virus to change as
well as the population changes say for
during famine or wars that can put
pressures on the evolving virus
population as well so it's very
complicated it's not a very it's not a
straightforward cut-and-dried situation
a dead end interaction is what happens
in many cross-species infections
typically not intraspecies so when we
get viruses from other humans they're
not typically dead end infections this
what would happen for example Marburg or
Ebola going from a bat to a human often
the host is killed very quickly so there
is no transmission but the virus is also
not adapted very well for transmission
to other hosts and that's here the new
in fact that host cannot transmit maybe
the virus doesn't replicate well in the
new host
can kill the host but it doesn't make a
lot of particles so they're not
effectively transmitted to other hosts
it may be something that could evolve
over time but often it just doesn't you
haven't the right collection of viruses
to do that so these contribute very
little to spread Ebola is scary but it
doesn't spread amongst people and so all
the hype on the cover of Newsweek is
really hype because there's no evidence
that it's much of a threat unless you go
to Africa and you contact a bat that has
the virus in it so let's look at a
couple of these life cycles just so that
you understand what's involved well we
instead of just putting the words on the
board so here's an arbol virus arbovirus
is a word that simply means
arthropod-borne and it can include
viruses from multiple families and here
is an example of an arbol virus that is
involved in a stable host virus
relationship in wild birds and it's
transmitted among the wild birds by a
mosquito vector so this is a stable
interaction the mosquito is fine the
birds are fine they can transmit it to
other hosts if another mosquito bites
some of these birds and involve another
cycle as well so it can be complicated
and often domestic animals like chickens
can be infected and they are part of the
natural cycle and they don't get sick as
well so that's a stable interaction
there can be dead end hosts so when the
mosquito bites a horse or a human they
can get infected they can have disease
because there are new hosts for this
virus but they typically don't spread it
to other hosts so how is this spread
it's spread by a mosquito vector they
typically don't pick up virus from
people and spread it to someone else so
that's a dead end host and a stable host
virus interaction here's another example
of stable and dead end hosts with simply
another kind of virus and another vector
this time it's a tick-borne virus which
transmits the virus among rodents so it
goes from one road into another by the
tick bite the tick is fine the rodent is
fine it's a stable virus host
relationship even some goats can be the
virus can be passed to
but they don't get silk they don't get
sick although there is no evidence that
these are part of the natural cycle and
then when these tix bite humans which
happens if you go walking in the woods
and you get ticks on you they can bite
you and give you viruses so you're a
dead end host and you're likely to
develop some kind of disease depending
on the virus and if you drink goat's
milk that hasn't been sufficiently
heated you can pick up the virus as well
other kinds of dead end infections so
we've looked at couple just generally
yellow fever is a dead end infection as
well as dengue dengue now is moving into
a cycle in humans but certainly yellow
fever is maintained in the forests in a
cycle between monkeys and mosquitos the
monkeys are fine the mosquitos are fine
when people go into the forest they get
bitten by the mosquitos and they get
yellow fever so if you're trying to
build a Panama Canal there are lots of
mosquitoes around you're going to get
yellow fever Marburg and Ebola virus is
the highly lethal ones hendra and NEPA
and SARS as we'll talk about again or
all viruses that cause dead end
infections they go from bats to humans
also other types of viruses Lassa virus
the one we talked about earlier and a
few related viruses are dented
infections from rodents so so we'll talk
about sin nombre virus in a bit and this
rarely this doesn't really spread among
humans it goes from mice to humans and
their number of infections in each of
them is initiated by a mouse laboratory
animal models can be viewed as dead end
infections as well because typically
don't they don't transmit well amongst
the animals or if they do you have to
have some unusual conditions so putting
guinea pigs and cages next to each other
with air blowing between them is a good
way to transmit influenza virus but for
the most part the lab infection is a
dead end so the transgenic mice that we
talked about susceptible to polio you
can infect them but they don't transmit
it to one another we use them for
studying the infection in the infected
animal but we can't study how the virus
moves
population so too when an infection
emerges which as we defined earlier
means is the new infection or
rediscovery of an old one you have two
general steps that have to occur first
the virus has to be introduced somehow
into the population and that's where all
those factors come into play travel
incursion and forests for deforestation
or moving into new environments or
ecological changes societal changes all
that helps introduce the viruses into
population but then of course it has to
establish itself and disseminate and as
we said often there's no establishment
there's a brief infection and then it's
over what is scary those are the viruses
are still there we never know when
they're going to infect us so
encountering new hosts this is probably
happening more than we now here in New
York City of course there aren't there
are probably many novel viruses that are
potentially going to potentially infect
us there's not a lot of wildlife would
be interesting to go to Central Park and
survey there for viruses but for the
most part the encounters are going to
happen in areas where there are there
are borders between where humans live in
animals so there are a lot of encounters
even in those regions if you live where
there are bats for example you probably
are infected now and then but you never
detect the infection because it never
takes hold so you get single so-called
single host infections you go in a cave
you go cave exploring you inhale some
aerosol which is generated from the bats
you get some viruses in you they
probably never replicate probably
happens more than we know so they don't
replicate in this or if they do and you
go home that evening you don't spread it
to someone else and there are many
reasons why you have the virus f2 of
course find cells that are both
susceptible and permissive they have to
have receptors and they have to have all
the internal machinery working and if
this is a virus evolving in animals it's
probably hard you know it might be a
member of the Kwazii species but finding
it is is luck and so that's why it's a
very rare event population density
inhale and your health are important so
if you're really robust
healthy have a great immune system
you're not likely to be infected and if
there's not much population around to
transmit the virus to it won't spread
remember fires to survive because they
establish serial infections a chain of
transmission and if you are living in an
area that's not very populated then
you're not going to transmit the
infection so how do we meet new viruses
we're always finding new ways as I said
air travel building dams and fooling
with water irrigation you spray water on
a crop and maybe the water is
contaminated as viruses in it and people
working in the fields are going to
inhale this rerouting wildlife migration
patterns wildlife parks hot tubs we
talked about if you don't sanitize them
properly air conditioning blood
transfusion and transplanting tissues
from other animals in two hours it can
have viruses in them long-distance
transport of animals is a big one moral
and societal changes with regard to drug
and sex massive deforestation tires
urbanization and day care centers it's a
big one so these are just a few of the
ways that we have provided and a lot of
them are new so they weren't happening
100 years ago and that's why there are
there are more incidences of viruses
crossing over into into us and so to
take this a little further let's see how
this actually works so there are many
ways that you can get viruses from other
hosts and so for example hunting and
consumption of wild game contact with
animals at zoos and that that happens
you'll see the West Nile outbreak might
have involved contact with mosquitos at
least that we're feeding off zoo animals
so that will give you infected bodily
body fluids sharing a resource with
different species infected bats pigs and
humans share the same space this often
happens as we will see sharing of insect
or Road into vectors so for example
Japanese encephalitis virus is spread by
mosquitoes that feed on three different
moves the virus around so if humans go
where there are pigs and herons that
have the virus you're going to get
infected an encroachment is a big one we
enter the jungle and we get bitten by
mosquitoes that are part of this cycles
these stable cycles that we don't know
about I get a new disease and that's
exactly what yellow fever was so here is
a fruit bat anyone ever seen a fruit bat
before give a pick one up there about
three feet yeah you've picked one up no
the wingspan is like this so there are
little cute cuddly things are pretty big
but I understand they're not nasty at
all in Australia and South East Asia
unfortunately people want to kill them
because they're associated with these
viruses that infect people but they're
doing it unknowingly of course they're
not bad so this is a fruit bat and
they're so far for previously unknown
paramyxovirus have been isolated from
them since 1995 and two of them will
talk about nepa and Hendra viruses the
three of these cause disease and pigs
and horses race horses and pigs raised
for food of course and have infected
humans and just to remind you
paramyxovirus azure envelope RNA
containing viruses glyco proteins on the
surface and a helical RNA inside of them
so these these animals are fine they're
not sick from infection of all these
viruses in fact bats have dozens and
dozens of viruses in them there there is
a an ongoing study several ongoing
studies right now where people are
collecting bat feces in the country and
sequencing it and you just find hundreds
of different viruses you find insect
viruses because the bats eat insects you
find plant viruses you find herpes
viruses you find all kinds of virus for
some reason they are a great host and
these bats are all fine so you should
stay away from bats because they have a
lot of viruses that could infect you so
nipah virus was first identified in 1998
in malaysia it was an outbreak of
respiratory and neurological disease on
pig farms and this ended up yielding a
hundred and five human deaths many more
infected and they they realized that the
virus was
from the pig so they killed the million
pigs this is a practicum in practice
when livestock are infected to kill the
whole whole herd because you have no
idea the extent of infection and of
course for the farmers this is really
bad what happens here is that fruit bats
excrete the virus in the urine they're
fine as I have said pig farmers tend to
plant mango trees next to the pig pens
and at night the bats come and they eat
the mangoes and they urinate on the
fruit and then the next day the pigs eat
the mangoes that have fallen to the
ground and they get infected with the
virus pigs get sick and then the pig
handlers come in to take care of the
pigs and they get sick as well so it
goes from bats to pigs to humans so a
solution would be to get rid of the
mango trees I suppose hendra is a
similar paramyxovirus discovered in
hendra Australia September 1994 this was
an outbreak in a race horse stable so
this is big money here race horses are
expensive kill 14 race horses in the
trainer it was taking care of them in
fact the veterinarian who was involved
in this emailed me last year and he he
discovered our podcast and he said I
made I'd be happy to come on your
podcast and tell you about it so I have
yet to get him on but it would be
interesting I don't know if that was his
accent he may have been this virus came
from flying foxes again to horses so
somehow the flying foxes contaminated
probably horse feed that's out in the
open and then the horses eat it and get
infected then the humans are taking care
of the race horses and they get infected
as well and at the bottom is the extent
of spread of this virus initially
starting in Australia right here whereas
whereas hendra it's not on the map
anyway here in nineteen ninety four
ninety four the P near Brisbane yeah and
then it spread throughout the northern
coast and also to other parts of
Southeast Asia as well but as I said
there's no evidence that it's going from
person to person they're just outbreaks
which all come from
Fox's here's an example of a yellow
fever outbreak member yellow fever is a
dead end type of infection it's in a
cycle between mosquitoes and monkeys in
the forest and then you humans encroach
so it's a tropical infection because the
mosquitoes don't live when it gets too
cold and this is an example of an
outbreak in Philadelphia in 1793 was
imported from Santo Domingo so people
come on boats and they go to
Philadelphia they're infected they don't
have symptoms so they come in and then
the virus can be spread amongst humans
it's an unusual cycle and here's a case
count from august to november this is
daily burials big outbreak quite a bit
of the population was affected and then
in late october november it stopped
because of the mosquitoes were killed by
the cold temperatures in philadelphia so
you can bring the diseases elsewhere as
well if you have enough humans to
sustain transmission of the virus there
are also many examples of diseases of
exploration that we've touched on very
briefly these are also emerging
infections when when a colonist brings a
virus to a new population to them it's
an emerging infection and when this
happens you often have explosive
epidemic spread remember the population
has never seen this virus maybe it's
measles virus that emerged with
domestication of cattle in the Middle
East it's never been to the new world
but it gets brought there at some point
by someone and then it explodes so an
example of smallpox came from the Far
East to Europe and 710 ad never been in
Europe before and exploded in the
population killed a lot of people
smallpox changed the balance of
populations in the New World three and a
half million Aztecs we think were killed
by smallpox probably also measles in two
years after the virus was was brought
there from Hispaniola probably allowing
conquest by a vastly overmatched Cortez
expedition
this doesn't happen now of course
because with global travel viruses can
be everywhere but there's always the
possibility that a brand new virus comes
into a new population and you have
explosive spread I don't think it would
happen because with medicine being so
good and responsive nowadays we can
probably quell the outbreak so there's a
new movie coming out in a couple of
months October so when you guys are gone
remember it's called contagion it's
about this kind of scenario this is just
ended filming now and it's got Matt
Damon and Kate Winslet and the guy from
the matrix with the bald head yeah I
Lori Laurence Fishburne and also some
other stars so it's a budget movie and
it was made in consultation with Ian
Lipkin who is a neurologist up at the
Medical Center so you'll hear his name
in it so check it out sorry oh here he
helped write the script yeah yeah he got
paid for it he's very happy he's very
happy to have dealt with it and they
mentioned his name in it so he's really
happened contagion actually Kate and
Kate Kate Winslet and Matt Damon went to
his lab for like two days to learn how
to pipette so they wouldn't look like
idiots in the movie good but he had his
text teach them he didn't do it himself
so because he doesn't add a pipette
anymore I guess polio is another example
of an emerging infection this time by
changes in human populations and
environments polio emerged at the
beginning of the 20th century because of
improvements in sanitation the virus has
been around probably since four thousand
years ago but just caused a little case
here and there just small isolated cases
was it was a stable host virus
relationship but then we improved
sanitation and delayed infection till
when we were older instead of when we
were babies and that made the virus more
leaflet made it cause paralysis more
quently and so at the beginning of the
20th century probably also coupled with
development of urban centers it became
an epidemic so here's an exact days our
annual reported cases of polio with with
year starting in 1885 you see a little
blip here in the late 1890s and then
just after the turn of the century large
outbreaks in the US on the scale that
had never been seen before you know 20
30 thousand cases a year in the US and
that's why we developed a vaccine for
this disease as we have taught as we
have talked about changing climate and
animal populations is another reason for
emergence this one is hantavirus
pulmonary syndrome a novel kind of
respiratory infection first noted in the
Four Corners area right there where the
four states you can stand right there on
all four states at once if you up 1993
what happened here was the viral a
number of individuals had developed
really serious respiratory disease a
number of them died the virus was
isolated turned out to be this virus
seen nombre virus which is a hantavirus
and this virus is endemic in the deer
mouse peromyscus maniculatus which is
present in many parts of the US
especially right here at the four
corners originally this virus was called
Marco Canyon virus because that's where
the first isolate came from near the
four corners but the people who live in
worth o Canyon didn't want the name of
their town associated with a lethal
virus so they mounted a PR campaign and
it was changed I think it was also going
to be called four corners and they
didn't like that either so they ended up
going up C nombre as kind of a final
word so this is a hantavirus these are
also RNA viruses envelope to have
genomes that are in three pieces in s
and M and an LPS so these are deer mice
peromyscus maniculatus and what happened
was in 1990
to it was a lot of rainfall more more
than usual and as a result there were a
lot of pinon nuts these are nuts that
the deer mice like and also people eat
them for good very expensive here in New
York City but you can grow them out
there there was big crops this year so
there are a lot of mice and the mice got
into people's homes and the mice carry
the virus and the virus is present in
urine and excreta of the mice and it
eros Eliza's and infects the people so
more mice more contact with humans and
then they found virus and contaminated
blankets and dust on the floors of the
homes of the people who were infected so
we are not the natural host for this
virus and it doesn't go from person to
person it goes from a mouse to you and
there can be a lot of infections in a
given time if there are a lot of mice
excreting virus but it doesn't transmit
so it's a dead end kind of infection so
this is the distribution of cases of
infection with seen nombre virus these
are the orange dots and the green is the
crew distribution of the mouse
peromyscus maniculatus so you can see
the two go quite well hand in hand there
are a few isolated cases outside of the
normal range of the mice probably due to
travel there was actually a case out on
Long Island just won a number of years
ago probably not the same virus but
highly related and probably spread by a
different kind of mouse so as of 2003
349 cases so not a lot but it's it's
again an example of what can happen when
the conditions change in this case a big
rainfall these are other viruses related
to see nombre virus there's distributed
all over the new world as you can see
there they're vector door they're
carried by various rodents so here's
peromyscus and sin nombre the virus in
New York on Long Island was peromyscus
carried by peromyscus Luca pasa
different mouse species so all these are
different viruses great names blood land
Lake virus because and carried by
different rodents the yellow ones are
those that have been
associated with human diseases so you
can see there are a lot of these around
and in there's some condition some of
them are going to jump to people
probably in a similar way that scene
nombre virus did so there are lots of
opportunities as we move into new areas
so this is a warning that diseases lurk
in the wild if we intrude upon another
host parasite relationship so the host
parasite relationship here is the virus
and it's Mouse host they're fine we
intrude on it and we get infected SARS
is another example of a infection a
zoonosis this one spread from person to
person and this was one of the this
initiate this began in China and this is
an early email so promed mail is a
infectious disease monitoring system you
can have them send you emails or you can
go to their website this is one from
februari 10 2003 this morning I received
this email does anyone know anything
about this problem have you heard of an
epidemic in gwangsu an acquaintance of
mine from a teacher's chat room lives
there and reports that the hospitals
have been closed and people are dying so
this was the first report of something
going on over there and this turned out
to be the SARS epidemic severe acute
respiratory syndrome so it began in this
province in china in november of 2002
severe atypical pneumonia so it didn't
resemble any pneumonia that anyone had
seen before more severe and features
radiographic features that were
different the initial outbreak 305 cases
five deaths incubation period two to ten
days illness begins with the typical
nonspecific symptoms that we've talked
about of a virus infection followed by
dry cough shortness of breath and that
some of these infected patients may
require mechanical ventilation they
cannot breathe because of the
destruction to the lungs so it was
called severe acute respiratory syndrome
initially because they didn't know what
was causing it eventually they
identified a virus which we will talk
about there was a Chinese doctor who had
treated some of the first patients in
China from that outbreak that we just
discussed he didn't know he was sick but
he tried
to hong kong on februari of 2003 stayed
at this nice hotel the metropole hotel
is the famous metropole hotel because of
this incident he ended up in fact thing
he died in the hospital the next day
alright but he had already infected 10
other people in this hotel and a flew on
to wherever they live Singapore Vietnam
Canada us and they brought the virus
with them and that's how the virus got
around the world from this initial
physician who left without knowing that
he was ill in the end it went to 8,000
people in 29 countries with about ten
percent mortality so what is this virus
it was a new member of the coronavirus
family we haven't talked really at all
about these viruses but they are a
pretty diverse group of RNA containing
viruses they have an envelope there are
viruses of many different species you
can see here they're classified into
three antigenic groups humans pigs dogs
cats etc so there a number that infect
humans and here's the new sars
coronavirus in group 2 so that was a
brand new virus that was isolated from
these individual these are the virions
their envelope electron micrographs you
can see like what they're called
coronaviruses because in the e/m they
had this Corona around the outside you
know member rotaviruses were called
wheels because they look like wheels is
the same thing the electron microscopist
are very inventive and this is an
envelope the RNA virus as a single long
RNA genome it's the longest RNA genome
we know of over 20 kilobases with
glycoproteins in the envelope in humans
there are five different coronaviruses
that cause disease mainly respiratory
disease some of them can cause lower
tract infections but this one is the
only one the sars coronavirus that
causes a typical pneumonia it's spread
as you would guess by respiratory
secretions risk factors include health
care workers the doctor who worked in
China for example the virus seems to be
ubiquitous and we have no vaccines or
antivirals against them you inhale the
virus it replicates in your respiratory
mucosa and spreads throughout you
or respiratory tract it does not enter
your blood so it doesn't go below the
basement membrane stays restricted to
the respiratory tract and how it causes
severe disease we don't really
understand but probably involves an over
stimulation of the immune system what
was very interesting about the SARS
outbreak was that there was a very
effective global alert system put in
place primarily by the World Health
Organization and this really helped to
limit the spread of infection so for
example remember the original outbreak
was in February and March there was a
global alert announcing the name of the
disease advice given to travelers to be
careful of infected area kaif that case
definition was provided by the end of
the month it was decided that people
with the disease were traveling and that
that proposed some kind of a risk so
they wanted everyone to be aware of that
and then guidance was provided to screen
passengers to decrease the transmission
so in China in particular there were
measures put in place that would prevent
people that were suspected to be
infection of leaving the country so this
is a graph of the outbreak in Hong Kong
which began with the physician bringing
the virus there you can see the the
epidemic peak here in March and then
going down by June 1753 cases just as
just in June sorry in Hong Kong so Hong
Kong suffered some economic consequences
is a poster that actually Ian Lipkin
brought back from his trip to Hong Kong
Hong Kong will take your breath away so
apparently they stopped using these
posters after the outbreak of SARS so
this is a collector's item and here's an
airport is the Hong Kong Airport
deserted because these alerts put out by
wh 0 really discouraged travel among the
so the probable cases worldwide as of
2003 are shown here you can see it
spread to Canada and the US Europe China
Hong Kong Taiwan Singapore Thailand
Austria
in Vietnam so the main countries hit
were China and Canada as you can see
eight thousand cases in ten percent case
fatality rate so this is an example of
the kinds of public relations that were
conducted to try and get people aware of
this in the airports in China they were
detectors that could tell if someone had
an elevated temperature so in order to
get on did you go through any of these
you remember these h1 did they use they
brought them out again for h1n1 yeah so
you had a walkthrough detector you go
through your security detector you go
through this if you have a fever you
have to go back to your hotel you can't
get on the plane so that probably helped
restrict a lot of spread of this
infection there are lots of posters
placed in public areas such as these to
prevention of atypical pneumonia with
hints about how to prevent spread so
this really had a big effect because we
didn't have a vaccine or an antiviral
the only way you could stop in spread of
the virus was to prevent travelers as
goes here so we had a early warning and
surveillance case investigation and
contact tracing of all the cases that
were involved and as I said the only
thing we had available was travel
restrictions quarantine and public
education so that helped and I think
that's part of the reason why the
outbreak was was stopped but where did
it come from so this is an emerging
infection so let's talk about where sars
coronavirus came from so human syrah
collected before the outbreak don't have
antibodies to the virus so that means
it's a new virus entering humans as is
around before and it's just really the
very earliest cases in China were
handlers of animals for the exotic food
mark how do i pronounce this name is it
guandong yeah it's good one dawg I don't
pronounce the G right okay handlers of
animals for the exotic food market so
there are markets like this where you
can purchase meat and you can see it's
slaughtered but uncooked so a number of
these early cases where people
like this fellow not him in particular
but cut up the meat and sell it so they
were that suggested that maybe virus was
in some of this meat and these animal
traders in general had higher prevalence
of antibodies than control groups so
even though not all of them became ill
they had a lot of antibodies which
suggested that they were in particular
particular risk for being infected so
let's look at the car analogy in China
early on to get some clues about what
happened here the first case recognized
on November 16 2002 and then a next one
in December 11 cases eight among medical
staff so suggesting transmission from a
patient in the index patient was a cook
in a restaurant so here you get the cook
is cooking these meats he or she got
them uncooked of course with the
potential for spread of the virus
December the first case here and 28
cases 13 in medical staff so again
people get ill to go to the hospital and
they infect the good deals of the
medical staff and this continued and
then eventually the first community case
in gwangsu so here are some antibody
serology numbers in these different
areas in Guangdong sorry among different
occupations so here are wild animal
traders so this was done of course after
the outbreak began 20 of them forty
percent had antibody to the virus animal
slaughterers of fifteen twenty percent
had antibodies vegetable handlers were
ok so this virus didn't come from plants
and the control group Hospital hospital
staff who didn't work in areas where
they were respiratory patients didn't
have of sixty of them they didn't have
any antibodies so this gave a lot of
clues about how the virus was spreading
then the virus was isolated from
Himalayan palm civets in the live animal
market in Guangdong in May of 2003
that's a palm civet and they eat them
there so they're hanging there in the
market you can buy them and they took
some of these and they found virus in
them and so there was epidemiological
evidence and sequence evidence that in
fact the infections came from civets to
humans
so the the markets were effectively shut
down you couldn't sell meat live meat in
those markets for a long time all the
civets they could find were killed and
eventually the infection stopped but
probably this is not the reservoir the
virus all the viruses they got from
various civets were really identical
which is not likely to be the case if
they're it's a reservoir for the virus
you would expect to find more diversity
and they didn't find the virus on civets
on farms or in the wild only in the ones
in the market and then the virus by this
timely it isolated this virus and
sequence knew exactly what it was could
be grown in culture eventually was
isolated from horseshoe bats in
different regions of China and these
these have been isolated from bats over
a thousand kilometres apart and
eighty-four percent of the bats that
have been looked at have antibodies to
this virus which strongly suggests that
this is the reservoir for infection the
identity of the sequence identity is 88
to ninety two percent between the bat
isolates and the human or the civet
strains so these could easily be the
precursor they pass through a bottleneck
and then in humans and civets they're
all very similar so there's more genetic
diversity in the bat viruses which you
would expect if they are the reservoir
of the infection so the idea now is and
we can't prove it but bats are the
reservoir somehow they get into civets
that are then brought to the market it's
not clear how this occurs and why it's
not present in civets in the wild so bat
to civet and then to human so no bats
there are no bats in the in the meat
markets they're just civets now this is
an interesting question how did the
virus adapt to us so presumably to go
from a bat to a human and replicate
pretty well in people it had to undergo
some selection so we the scientific
community sequenced hundreds of SARS
genomes from people from civics during
and after the epidemic
and they wanted to know which changes
led to adaptation of this virus to
humans and one of the areas that was
looked at extensively is the spike
glycoprotein that is one of the proteins
in the membrane of the virus which is
you know attaches to cell receptors for
many viruses it's a determinant of
species specificity it determines what
kinds of species are infected by the
particular virus and what they found was
that in this glycoprotein the human
incivek strains differ by only four
amino acids in the area of this
glycoprotein that binds the receptor for
amino acid differences between human and
civet viruses but there is a greater
than 1,000 full difference in the
binding affinity of that glycoprotein to
the cell receptor right for me no acids
cause this big difference in affinity
the receptor is a stew human angiotensin
converting enzyme to which happens of
course to be a a plasma membrane
glycoprotein so this suggested that
these changes maybe we're involved in
adaptation to human so the sivad virus
is don't bind very well to human cells
but then with form you know acid changes
they do so you can imagine that in the
pool of sivad viruses the quasi species
there are some that have these four
amino acid changes so when you get a
bolus of virus from a civet in the meat
market the ones that bind well to human
cells replicate and then those are
selected for so that's a reasonable
hypothesis so this is just a cartoon of
what happens here so here is the
receptive drawing of the receptor here
on the top this is a human sars receptor
a stew and this is the SARS spike like a
protein binding to it as a nice
extensive binding site high affinity
acts as a good receptor and this is the
situation for viruses identified between
2002 and 2003 now the civet SARS
glycoprotein has a couple of minute I
said four amino acid changes in two of
them as you can see here are right in
this binding area and in the idea is
that they reduce the affinity of the
glycoprotein for its receptor and these
two
have been looked at structurally so this
is probably correct so that's why the
civets trains probably initially don't
infect humans unless you select out a
variant from the civet pool that has
these for me no acid changes this is the
sequence of a human strain isolated from
humans in 2003-2004 so this was from an
outbreak which was much more mild than
that caused by the original virus and
you can see there are changes in this
glycoprotein which reduced its affinity
also for the cell receptor so this
suggests that that this these changes
were important for adaptation to humans
whether it's the only chain that that's
important we don't know and finally on
the right is the binding of a rat's arse
virus sorry oommen SARS virus
glycoprotein from 2002 2003 to a rat
receptor so human strains don't infect
rat cells very well and the reason is
that the receptors don't interact very
well so will it come back so since then
there has been no transmission of SARS
in the world at all the last cases were
laboratory acquired in April of 2004
seems to be gone and I just heard that
well the funding for doing SARS research
is basically gone in the US as a
consequence so all these labs that
expand it after the SARS outbreak by
getting money to study this now there
they can't do it anymore because there's
no perceived importance to doing this as
I said there was there was a previous
outbreak between december and january
five cases and this was a brand new
transmission from animal to human you
could tell by the sequence but this
these were the mild cases and that's
where that isolate came from that
doesn't bind very well to the receptor
there are certainly plenty of these
viruses and animals and meat markets are
now opened again in southern China so
nothing really has changed so i don't
know maybe it will come back again maybe
the situation was perfect for its
transmission and we won't have it again
but if it does emerge we can recognize
it right away
and probably contain it a lot quicker so
this is the outbreak of SARS it here
began the beginning of 2003 the yellow
bars just happened at the end of the flu
season which is the gray bars here so
for a while it was thought to be
influenza it confused a lot of people so
before the emergence of the sars
coronavirus we knew about 12
coronaviruses there was not much
research done on these viruses because
they were generally benign human
infections now we have over 36
coronaviruses and over 4,000
publications but now as I said this is a
dying research area because there's no
more infections as far as we can tell
okay so that's ours another interesting
emergence of viruses is canine
parvovirus anybody have a dog here that
was immunized for parvo virus well if
you do have a dog you should get it
immunized otherwise it could die from it
and this virus only emerged in 1978
didn't exist before that all right so
canine parvovirus brand new infection of
the intestine and the heart in dogs and
evolved from a cat virus feline
panleukopenia virus common virus of cats
somehow the virus around 1978 got from a
cat into a dog and then just took off
and that virus that's now well adapted
to dogs doesn't affect cats anymore cats
still have feline panleukopenia but the
new virus that they gave to dogs can't
infect them innate anymore so this is
the gift of cats to their canine friends
canine parvovirus so now we have to
immunize our animals against it so where
did this virus come from because it was
a pretty recent jump from cats to dog it
was possible to go back and get all the
initial isolates well the Syrah from
animals and really trace where this
virus came from do all the sequencing
and it looks like an ancestor to this
virus began infecting dogs in Europe in
the 1970s
it's spread by fecal-oral contamination
you know it's on the sidewalks most
likely and its people stepping it and
spread it around even get on an airplane
and bring it around the world and then
dogs of course are always eating
everything so that's how it got into the
dog that's how it infects dog by
fecal-oral contamination and sequencing
of all the early isolates made it
possible to determine that to amino acid
changes in the viral capsid is all that
it took for this cat virus to then
infect mouse cells to amino acid changes
so this is a diagram of the capsid of
this virus this is a DNA containing
virus single-stranded with an
icosahedral capsid the receptor is the
transferrin receptor which is shown here
not attached to the cell membrane just
stuck on the binding site so there are
two amino acid changes in the capsid
here that allow the virus to buy now dog
transferrin receptor instead of the cat
transferrin receptor so this is a really
nice story that was since it was recent
we could sort out because we had all the
isolates so the original variants that
involved in dogs have evolved in dogs so
this is an evolving virus host
relationship it's still changing there
are now two distinct strains as opposed
to be one initial one and its continuing
to vary so this virus is now global it's
all around the world and it's varying
extensively I guess at some point it
will evolve to be stable within the host
but since it's relatively do it hasn't
yet done that so that's canine
parvovirus so the principle is this was
a pretty rare event we don't know many
of these Soho strange switches by well
adapted viruses are rare so the cat
virus is well adapted to the cat to
switch a host like this is rare but we
saw it happen in real time and when it
occurs the outcome can be severe so dogs
are made very sick by this and that's
why you need to immunize them against
this virus in addition new variants
continue to spread so this is an
evolving virus host relationship so over
the years you get new variants made even
in new dogs and who knows eventually
what will happen
great opportunity to study virus host
adaptation all right another kind of
emergence is caused by our use of food
animals and 9 in that 2009 as we have
discussed a new pandemic influenza virus
emerged the h1n1 swine origin virus
which as I've told you before probably
arose by a variety of reassortant in
pigs of a variety of different viruses
and some of those parental viruses were
avian strains so the swine trade has
grown over the years since the early
nineteen hundred raising pigs for food
and this has increased the number
variation of influenza virus strains
because the viruses replicate very well
in pigs some of the genes that this h1n1
strain has are derived from avian
strains of influenza now in contrast to
flu in humans avian flu is a
gastrointestinal infection so you ever
hear people say I have stomach flu do
you think that's influenza virus
replicating in your stomach I hope you
say no it's not it's not influenza does
not get out of your respiratory tract
maybe they have our rotavirus or a
norovirus but it's not influenza but
birds can say I have stomach flu because
the virus does infect in the
gastrointestinal tract and this leads us
to the h5n1 story in 1996 this virus
first appeared in wild fowl in China so
there was a very extensive global flu
monitoring program where aquatic birds
are sampled on a regular basis to see
what's in them in terms of influenza so
this was first found in 1996 it wasn't
terribly pathogenic but it started to
spread too domesticated ducks and
chickens and infect herds and as it did
so it became more and more virulent and
eventually infected people in Hong Kong
in 1997 and since then it has continued
to infect people
a steady rate in certain areas but not
much if any person to person about
transmission so this is now called
pathogenic h5n1 influenza and i am sure
you've you have heard about it from
china and moved to india europe in
africa in less than 10 years and it
spread mainly by migratory birds these
are wild birds that have the infection
they're okay with it they spread it to
domesticated birds in these countries
humans also spread infections there's a
big exotic bird trade if you didn't know
people like to illegally purchase exotic
birds and bring them home and they often
bring the virus with them they don't
know the birds are infected and their
stink there's snuck into the country in
some way and they bring and this is
another way that h5n1 has been spread to
Europe cats can be infected in a zoo in
Thailand some some big cats were fed
chickens that happen to be infected with
h5n1 they didn't know it when they fed
it to them but the cats got sick and
they found out that they had h5n1 so it
has a pretty broad host range so this is
currently the global extent of h5n1
influenza virus in light shade it's in
wild birds and darker yellow it's in
poultry as well as in wild birds it's a
quite extensive and then in humans these
are the human cases mainly Asia Middle
East and parts of Africa not yet here in
the North or South America and not clear
why yet and so far since that first
outbreak in Hong Kong in 97 549 cases
pretty high mortality rate 320 deaths
you can see those are the red areas here
and the most have been in Indonesia
Vietnam and quite a few in Egypt as well
watch out if you go back to Egypt for
yeah it does it does they got to take it
within 48 hours otherwise marish good
don't be afraid to take it so this is
this is really scared a lot of people
and there are vaccines being developed
because people feel that this may be the
next major pandemic but you know it's
been here for over 10 years infecting
many people it doesn't yet have the
capacity to go from person to person it
goes from birds to people all the time
all those cases you can identify and for
the most part a bird that passed the
infection on to people so you know it
could I would be the first to say yeah I
could evolve to infect person to person
but it still hasn't happened yet and
maybe if it does it will lose some of
its pathogenicity so I'm not sure all
the fear is warranted it's good to be
aware but I don't think it you should be
afraid of it unless you're going to go
where there are chickens that have the
virus and could potentially get infected
now there are also examples of emerging
viruses that we just discover as we
improve our technology so so far we've
talked about viruses that we can grow in
cell culture you can discover them but
there are a number i want to tell you
about that we've discovered because of
techniques the Khaleesi biros is the
plus strand RNA viruses that cause a lot
of gastroenteritis that cause half of
all the foodborne outbreaks in the US 23
million cases a year can grow them in
cell culture so we only recently
identified them first by electron
microscopy and then my nucleic acid
sequencing techniques so that's that's
considered an emerging infection we are
seeing them more and more and these
viruses of we've talked about I believe
they're infected from for water and food
sources maybe we haven't talked about I
don't remember now have we talked about
lisi's maybe that was medical students I
talk to Sokka Lisi's are often found on
in theme parks because they're shed by
those big the whales and the jump out of
the water and splash you you know in
theme parks they excrete a lot of these
viruses and infections are passed on
that way cruise ships are great places
to get
c virus infections it's a closed system
the food handlers often shed them
without being sick and they contaminate
the food so they're and cruise ships are
now monitored very carefully and so you
can tell which ships have had outbreaks
you can go online and find a list of all
the cruise ships that have had outbreaks
in recent years because I said Marine
marine viruses include these calluses
and whales excrete a lot of viruses a
day in fact many animals including us
they're also in shellfish so you can get
them not only from marine mammals but
shellfish as well so that's a newly
emerged virus which we discovered as a
result of technology rotaviruses are the
same these are we did talk about these
in terms of a vaccine they infect every
child in the US not discovered until the
70s because we couldn't grow them we
couldn't detect them now we can grow
them quite well but in both of these
cases recombinant DNA and pcr allows us
to identify a nucleic acid and
associated with disease Pepsi is another
good example originally there were
people who didn't have hepatitis a they
didn't have hepatitis B so the blood
supply was screened for a third
potential hepatitis virus and this was
cloned from the serum of an infected
experimentally infected chimpanzee now
it can be grown in the laboratory for
many years it just existed as a DNA
sequence so in the end what do we do
about this this is a problem because it
costs a lot of money to detect these
emerging infections and prevent their
spread so we have to do a lot of
research which of course always costs
money you have to develop early
detection and we are doing that to a
great extent in this country we're
putting a lot of money into early
detection and identification technology
we have to have databases of all known
viruses in the ecosystem I have to
sequence everything we have to sequence
the world so that when you find
something new you can immediately say
this is it and get to work on making
something that can help the infection
that's not easy but it can be done we
have the technology to do it
you have to have actions planned out
ahead of time what are you going to do
and there are now people whose work is
just to plan out actions in response to
certain kinds of infection whether they
be natural or bioterror induced vaccines
drug stockpiles and quarantines are also
being developed in particular in this
country we're doing this for small pox
which as you know is eradicated so if it
comes back it will be an emerging
infection most likely by a bioterrorist
action but we have plans about what to
do exactly in the event of an outbreak
medical centers have training programs
where they have simulated outbreaks and
they go through what you would do if
this patient presented with the symptoms
of smallpox at what point do we announce
it do we put out vaccines and drugs etc
this is all developed and probably not
many people know about it and you need
to have a lot of communication at all
levels in order to coordinate this so
this is all very expensive but
discovering emerging viruses has led to
this so not only to having interesting
new science and understanding how people
are getting sick in new ways but an
unprecedented level of communication in
order to control these infections
you